nakta wave abroad forgets it back Butler
underneath couch fix yoga job
karl-anthony towns feasting
Harris
around Derrick Rose is not we haven't
gone through it you saving that for Rob
by good will see what I'm saving that
pervert if it's I think that's more of a
celebratory most otherwise it's due to
president it's true
by the time out quick canned off-guard
the card into a big pit
yeah well executed why John up by Mike
Milan for sure I mean Mike Malone who
was a video coordinator with the Knicks
in the early 2000s on the perimeter gets
into the paint and banks it in
how good is this kid clock down to five
Butler gets the high screen from Gibson
attacking Millsap fadeaway jumper
Millsap gets it in yo kitsch has it not
justify Teague has Millsaps covering him
Timberwolves don't have a timeout
Crawford election guy at the buzzer
world what the world but I mean that's
not an ideal play but at least you're
living to play another quarter who wants
to shine
Riggins Teague's gonna have to get it up
gets it up three seconds one second
it's finally over 13 years of
disappointment and frustration has come
to an end